For this question, you're asked to produce a list of words from a string,
which is separated either by white space or tags.
You've got to strip out all the tags.
We have tags here, here, here, here and here.
Now, we can't just remove the tags completely, because then we'd have
"Title" and this written as one word, and we don't want that.
The first thing I'm going to do is I'm going to remove the tags.
I'm going to search for the first tag, the opening tag and the closing tag,
and then I'm going to remove the whole of the tag.
But I'm not just going to remove it. I'm going to replace it with a space,
because replacing it by a space means that I don't have the problem with things like
"Titlethis" being run into one word.
Once I've got all the tags replaced by spaces, I'm going to use the split
that we've used before, which splits on white space.
Having several spaces in a row is not a problem,
because split removes the lot of them.
Now to look at how to code that.
We're asked to define a function remove_tag.
It takes a string as its input, and what I'm going to do first is I'm going to look for
the start position in the string--the start position of the first opening bracket.
I'm also going to need to find the end of the bracket--the end of the same tag.
Just to be on the safe side, make sure I find the right one, I'm going to start by looking at the start position.
I'm going to start the find from the initial opening bracket
and so I'll find the next closing bracket.
Now, that would find the first tag, but I'm going to have to do this multiple times
if there is more than one tag in the string.
While I have an opening tag--remember, if we have the string we're looking for non found,
then it returns -1.
As soon as we haven't got -1, we're going to keep looking for the tags and removing them.
Now to actually remove the tag, I'm going to break the string up.
I'm going to take the part before the tag and the part afterwards and joint them together.
I'm going to take the string up to start.
Now, this will actually exclude the opening tag, because it ends at one position less than start.
I'll replace the tag with a space and then I'll put the rest of the string after the tag at the end.
Now, I'll start at one position after the end, because end is the position of the closing tag,
and we don't want to include that.
Now I've got a new string. I'm going to see if I've got another tag that I'm going to have to remove.
I'm going to look for the next opening tag.
If I find an opening tag when it comes to the top of the while loop, it'll go through again.
If I don't find another opening tag, the while look will finish.
In that case, I want to return the string but not just the string.
I want it split into individual words.
Then I'm just going to split, and that almost completes the code,
except that I've misnamed the procedure and called it "remove_tag"
instead of remove_tags. And now we're done.